he's the new manager of the Angels Joe
Maddon joining us on the program Joe
what did you do with all your Cubs gear
well my son sold a lot of his Joey's
very loyal so Joey was on eBay I think
trying to get out this is an angel stuff
but now I'm gonna wear it proudly years
from now to listeners are great great
five years my god I've nothing to lament
about it winning the World Series after
108 and remember when we put up it was
spectacular so I don't have my son's
personality per se which is a good thing
but otherwise I'll keep the gear what's
the one memory that you'll keep from
winning the World Series like what's the
one that's etched in your mind oh the
globe you need to talk them up I'm
fighting the cold so you need other
token theater is you saw the slip
everybody saw the slip but when Katie's
slip there's like whoa and I ball came
out hot and a little bit high but of
course this is very tall but soon as the
gloves are the boss that Linda the glove
I really thought 108 that's my first
thought 108 normally I think about
coaches and what it means for coaching
staffs and and foreign offices and of
course the players fans but I thought
108 because the fans cut parents are so
loyal
everybody was tied to that moment so it
was 108 the moment the baldies Club Dave
Martinez the Nationals manager was bench
coach for a couple years in Tampa you
stayed in touch with him oh yeah we've
been texting recently on once I ran down
his new phone number we've been texting
and we went through that procedure he's
doing much better obviously I think he's
doing a great job
the other night when he brought in
Hudson when he would I've got that was
spectacular that was uh I don't know you
know if that's been talked about it up
that's kind of a game-changer right
there baby who knows what's going on in
the dugout I could I could attend to
that personally he and I would talk
constantly be anything so it doesn't
surprise me from that perspective plus
he's got a really nice team I mean these
guys are a real combination of old and
new
there's veterans and babies and babies
one of the best in the business so are
they and of course their coaching staff
is spectacular you know you hear from
coaches manager
and they talk about you know you kind of
have a shelf life now in today's world
in coaching and being a manager and that
you either need to hit the reset take a
year off a new challenge did give me the
feeling of you know was it time for you
and the Cubs to separate did you feel
that yourself I honestly didn't I became
more obvious to me at the end of the
fifth year and believe me there's no
disconnect between me and the players
there that anything that said or written
about that is clearly not truly my true
you know it's just a matter of the plain
office dealing said they just wanted to
move in a different direction you know
that that's their choice and I totally
respect it so from that perspective it's
more difficult to deal if you know
appeal that the front office doesn't
support you so that's not really where
they came down to and it was right it
was good as a visceral situation I felt
the same thing by the end I wanted to
move it along I wanted to get to a
different spot and this and of course
the English came open at the right time
but I stopped about I think maybe five
year shelf life in Chicago might be the
equivalent to seven to ten somewhere
else and that's good that's cool I have
nothing nothing but pure wonderful
thoughts about my time there but it
probably was a time to move on based on
I would finished out but believe me it
had nothing to do it me and the players
I've been getting I've been getting
texting and there's a piece of art that
will connect commissioned Contreras and
Yu Darvish some of the most interesting
and cool nor I've ever received from a
player so it's been very very humbly why
the Angels Pendleton high school Rafi at
college California Angels I got a chance
to come back at him
been gone for 15 years help meaning that
had I just been away for four or five
years there might not have been a big
enough gap I feel like it was time to go
back I needed to cut my feet somewhere
else that would have been Tampa Bay and
then of course Chicago the economy was
destroyed just like the time was
probably right to leave Chicago the
timing is definitely right to come back
here are
and I have always got along great Johnny
crap you know gotten to know Billy Epler
quickly and really really liked this guy
in his mind these razor-sharp brother
and then the players I mean is it makes
team on the field right here
the guy that should be the MLB logo and
then on top of that what we will we will
augment the pitching staff so cannot be
more excited I had a great time at the
press conference yesterday lot of the
old angel shall avail my buddies humming
moment I mean that glitchy glitchy
sitting over there
Langly Rod Carew I'm looking in my
mind's eye Mike wood was in the back
Garret Anderson Adam Kennedy everybody
was there man it was it was awesome how
would you describe Mike Trout to
somebody who'd never seen him play the
way this is how do you describe that's
this the way with a baseball player a
complete baseball player looks like if
you do keep coming down from the moon
and you want to know what baseball is
all about what a baseball player looks
like this is the guy check out Mike Mike
Trout suit who does it from the point of
this running mark I love guys that run
hard from home the first I consistently
does that defensively tracks everything
down as a fine arm and then of course at
the plate it's just different when you
met when you make a mistake it's hit
hard somewhere he's the holes that he
had had shown earlier on in this query
starting to cover he's got he's got
everything that he's just a complete
baseball player he's I mean of course he
fits the analytical mold because he's so
good
but this guy is just a different animal
and to be able to work with him on a
daily basis I'm so looking forward to
that he's Joe Maddon the Angels new
manager joining us Dan Patrick show what
number you going to wear how does David
seventy okay and I brought that up
yesterday Langley used to give me a hard
time about that mark Langston when I
showed up Jerry got to change your
number because I knew Langston allows
you to 1980 play in Boulder Colorado and
that I said lightly I mean they took a
bit when when I went on Sean came to the
Angels they gave one in 220 how dare he
take
you know I always laugh about it so I
dropped 20 I thinking about is also
thinking number 49 for Bob Claire who
was my mentor here for so many years the
best coach that nobody's ever heard of
Melba Lou I thought about that but at
the time when I was given number 70
unceremoniously in my locker it you know
actually parked but every year that was
I said I will never change this number
because nobody's gonna want it and and I
was actually right are you the greatest
number 70 in baseball history you know
we'll see when everything's done Jorge
Costas Worth and Whitney came over to
the cousins from an attorney had an
argument about who should keep number 70
at the end of the day I want to wear it
all the way through and we'll see how
this all plays out but I kind of got to
like it I kind of liked what I see maybe
when I saw folks were number 70 from a
distance I had a couple things to clear
up just in case people aren't aware of
your your history you intentionally
walked Josh Hamilton with the bases
loaded that was when you were with the
Rays how much crab okay so you you
intentionally want Josh Hamilton with
the bases loaded the Rays were up seven
three two outs in the ninth in it okay
and it worked out did you I know that
somebody was at Buck Showalter
intentionally walked Barry Bonds I think
with the bases loaded and they'd also
worked on for him did you get criticism
for doing that with Hamilton does it
work probably not as much
lilia criticize or things don't work
does it has nothing to do whether it was
a right or wrong for you to do in that
moment whether something works or not is
only but that's how things are gauged or
judged or remembered and but in that
moment Josh Hamilton was swinging the
bat bat well yeah and in that ballpark
in Texas the ball just jumps everywhere
I didn't really have a great matchup I
think I had grand fall for walked him at
that point with Marlon Byrd on deck and
Danny wheeler Danny wheeler is doing
really well for it so I just I like so
much better this the
moment of wheeler on Bert as opposed to
anybody in the world on Janet that's
what I did I mean so it just I mean in
that moment it makes all the sense in
the world now when you get to today's
again with the even greater scrutiny
then that was 2008 I believed and then
you get all the the Sanskrit is via you
know social media I think people may
tend to walk away from that moment now
and not be so inclined to do something
like that just in case it doesn't go
right I'm here to tell you what still do
it anyway but things have changed the
scrutiny is higher or heavier that
nevertheless in that moment brother in
that dugout in pectus on that night I
felt it was the right thing to do and
the other thing there was an eighty song
Jenny by Tommy tutone and you you had
your so 867-5309 and then you you you've
fixed your lineup with eight with
centerfield batting first followed by
the shortstop his second at sing so that
was on purpose did you get criticized
for that
DJ up then probably Jason Bartlett in my
life and then throw properly seven five
long ago three Carlos Pena who was the
VHF exactly that's a good question
that's who and I've Gabe gross I don't
even know I came over the year that I
did that but I'm thinking about the
players that may have been involved in
that the Tommy tutone lineup brother and
it's one we won with it so there's
Concord you know they just have some fun
people please I mean this is not life
and death sports are running games they
are and they should always remain that
way those that start treating it like
life and death
please wake up and smell the roses if
I'm an Angels fan what do I expect out
of this team now well I mean I you call
them I made it go see Billy upload a
couple minutes we're going to interview
some guys and I was thinking about that
quite frankly and there's I really think
we have to the spring training make our
mark and really have these our players
understand how important it is
to the show I mean show up every night
meaning the fundamentals the little
things we've got we've got to really get
into the menu tey of the game and really
think it's important every night and and
nothing can be thought of it's not
important and if I can get the guys to
really settling on that mentally and
have the coaching staff be dogged enough
which they will be to incorporate you
know as a manager I should not be
involved in the coaching as much
although I did a lot more this past
season so you really have to have
coaches that are willing to have
difficult decisions
I like fearless coaches I like and what
that means to me is that he will have
the tough discussion he will call BS on
somebody he doesn't have to be the best
coach that ever lived with that
particular skill set but he definitely
has to be able to have the tough
conversations and we were able to do
that from day one and that's what we're
talking about right now that's probably
what I'm going to talk about in the very
first day camp because it goes well
beyond repetition and number of ground
balls or swings or looking at data or
video charts it's about the heartbeat
brother and if you bring that every day
properly we deftly have the skill set to
make a lot of noise next year Belmar was
the belt Belle gnome who was the it was
heeded eh does that sound right oh yeah
don't know me Jersey New Jersey he was
up this was a great moment great
minor-league good guy I think his
parents were in attendance that night
well know me right beol yes yes yes okay
yeah that's right yeah yeah yeah now
he's part of a trivia question hey Joe
thanks for joining us good luck and we
hope to talk to you here when the season
starts that's Joe man angels manager for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]